There are many recommended sunnah. I'll
just pick up one which has come to my
mind. It is masjid.
The prophet in the juma salah. There is
no sunnah before juma salah. While
giving he saw a saba coming and sitting
he stopped this and asked him did you
offer your he said no. He said stand up
and offer. It's a recommended sunnah.
Not as highly recommended as all the ra
before.
Then the other sunnah
in which the prophet missed without any
reason. So if you want to offer salah go
in order. If you cannot do for certain
reason go to next. Don't offering to
after voodoo is good. I'm not against
it. But more important are the more
important your sunnah and then you can
go to that. So if you know the order of
the sunnah which is more important you
will get more salah and more chances of
entering Jenna and more chances of
washing away your sins.
So when you offering then you can offer
the other salah whether you're leaving a
house entering the house and you do
all these are sunnah but more important
so Muslim knows which is more important
he ties under the most important then
the second then the third let me give
you one more example
my staff in Malaysia
he offers alhamdulillah religiously
the third important pillar that is he
offers He does his fasting on Monday and
religiously mashallah. Very good.
Alhamdulillah.
But then I find that he's not doing the
other more important fasting. Fasting is
a for every Muslim in the month of
Ramadan besides Ramadan.
But someone is fasting on Monday,
Thursday. Very good. But then he's not
offering
the fasting of the first nine days of
dula. Maybe only one but not the first
eight days. So which is the most
important fasting after the fast of
Ramadan?
It is a fasting on Arafa. I won't go
into the reference. This time will take
time detail. A prophet said if you fast
on the day of Arafa two your sins will
be forgiven which is the second most
important sunnah fast. It is fasting on
ash the 10th of Arafa is the 9th of
Zula. Then is the 10th of Mar. The
prophet said if you fast and ashur your
one year sin will be forgiven. If you
add up both technically it's not one
year is not overlapping. It's not it's
three years because in the first the the
month that come first is only sorry it
comes next. But when it says two years
it says one year sin of the last year
and the next year. You come to Arafa the
year when you come to Muharam the year
changes
and the hadith says one year sin. So if
you add a both together it is three
years sin are forgiven. So the second
most important is fasting on the 10th
day of dulicha ashur. Then which is
important then the first eight days of
zulicha. The prophet said any deed done
in these 10 days of dujah
it is better than any other deeds.
Sabbath asked him even better than
jihad. He said yes even better than
jihad unless you go and you die and come
back without
your you die in the in the battlefield
and give up all your wealth. That is the
only deed better. So amongst the good
deed if you fast on the first eight days
nine ninth day is already covered by me
on the day of it is more important than
the other fasting.
So if you know the order, if you want to
fast those which are more important,
then you have the ayamulb
the three white days 13, 14th and 15th
of every month. Then you have the days
of Shawal 6 days. No difference opinion
which is of course shawal is some
scholars say more better than ayam but
the first three orders is there's no
difference opinion then you can come on
Monday and Thursday and today
while meet and greet the question came
on fasting and asked him which is the
most important sunnah fasting he said
Monday Thursday
the knowledge it's good I'm not against
fasting but if you're not keeping the
one day fast which will forgive your two
years sin or one day fast which will
forgive your one year's sin. So if you
know your priorities of the sunnah you
will get more sab
any sunnah you get will get sab but you
should know which is more important so
of course the salah [snorts] is more
important then comes fasting in fasting
which fasting is more important you know
people come and tell me you know I like
sweet dishes it's sunnah eating sweet
dishes of course the prophet loved sweet
dishes but the brothers not saying
bismillah before eating
Saying bismillah before eating food is a
more priority of sunnah than eating
sweet dishes. So I would request the
ummah today especially in the modern era
who's following the sunnah do a little
bit research which of the sunnah is more
important and try and do the more
important sunnah if it's impossible
to do all the sunnah and when I told the
brother the brother do you know that the
prophet never fasted every Monday and
Thursday he got the shock of his life
it's a sunnah to fast on Monday and
Thursday but the prophet never fasted
every Monday and every Thursday but the
brother is doing it. It's good. You can
do it. Alhamdulillah. But you do the
more important
sunnah. So in less sunnah you get more
saw.
So if we do a little research that which
sunnah is more highly recommended, which
is recommended, which is only a sunnah,
inshallah the chances that you go to
Jenna is higher.